[Music]
on this wednesday night first
face-to-face biden and putin's
high-stakes talks
the russian president's deflections why
the american president's not looking to
build trust
and was any progress made the green
party leader
defiant in the face of some who want her
gone
i am very excited about what is to come
what's behind the internal turmoil
and tension a powerful farewell speech
from an inuk
mp i shouldn't be afraid of going into
work nunavut's only
mp on why she's leaving politics
the cost of living climbs what's behind
the trend and
what could reverse it plus a soccer
superstars hard pass on a soft drink
and the impact it's had
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
two leaders two different views of the
world two men who don't speak the same
language
this is joe biden's first foreign trip
as american president and he agreed to
meet face to face with russian president
vladimir putin
who biden has said he thinks is a killer
today
biden said he did what he came to do
bottom line is i told president putin
that we need to have some basic rules of
the road
that we can all abide by
good evening and thanks for joining us
the relationship between russia and the
u.s can have repercussions for the whole
world and so all eyes were on this
summit
they talked for about two hours there
was no jovial joint news conference
afterward
jackson proskow was watching from
washington and has our top story tonight
they've crossed paths before but never
as equals
their summit was efficient and
substantive according to russian
president vladimir putin
u.s president joe biden suggested time
will tell
president putin and i had a share a
unique responsibility
to manage the relationship between two
powerful and proud countries
a relationship that has to be stable
and predictable biden came to geneva
looking to put guard rails around
russian activity
in ukraine in american elections and
around
cyber attacks but in a solo news
conference
after putin quickly returned to old
tactics
on cyber attacks the two countries
agreed to consult
but putin suggested russia isn't to
blame
the majority of cyber attacks are made
from u.s territory and the second one
is canada he said pressed by american
journalists on the jailing of political
opponents like alexi navalny
putin responded by pointing to the
arrest of the u.s capitol
insurrectionists
and the black lives matter protests
we do not wish that kind of thing should
happen on our territory he said
biden was far more frank about what
should happen if navalny dies in prison
i made it clear to him that i believe
the
consequences of that would be
devastating for
russia the relationship between the u.s
and russia has become increasingly
strained
both countries pulled their respective
ambassadors earlier this year
so you know vladimir putin you think
he's a killer
i do putin has been emboldened having
outlasted
and at times outplayed a succession of
u.s leaders
i looked the man in the eye i found it
to be very straightforward
and trustworthy in a stark break from
the cozy and mysterious relationship
between
putin and former president donald trump
biden took a more pragmatic view
suggesting he's not looking for
friendship or even trust
this is not about trust this is about
self-interest
and verification self-interest from the
outset the white house did not trust
that putin would not try to upstage
biden
they insisted that putin arrive at the
summit site first so as not to keep
biden waiting
and there was no joint press conference
but in a small sign of progress
both leaders did agree to restore their
respective ambassadors
to embassies in both countries donna
all right jackson proskow thanks
president biden says he raised the case
of an ex-u.s marine who is also canadian
and
holds citizenship in the u.s the uk and
ireland paul whalen was detained in
russia in 2018
accused of spying he was convicted last
june and sentenced to 16 years in prison
whalen maintains he is innocent he's
been pleading with biden to raise his
case
with putin so human rights is going to
always be on the table i told him
how could i be the president of the
united states of america
and not speak out against the violation
of human rights
after the meeting putin said there could
be a compromise on a prisoner's swap
biden said he would not walk away from
the plight of whaling and another
american detained
in russia canada's green party is in a
state of turmoil and its leader enemy
paul is vowing to stand
firm in the face of some in the party
who want her gone
she only took over last fall she doesn't
have a seat in the house of commons and
one of only three green mps just
abandoned the party and joined the
liberals
david aiken joins me from ottawa david
anime paul responded to all of this late
today what did she say
well donna anime paul is not backing
down
she sat through a marathon meeting
tuesday night
of the green party's governing council
and at the end of that meeting
a motion passed by a narrow vote of five
to four ordering paul to publicly rebuke
one of her staff members for crossing
swords
with the mp that defected that was
fredericton's jennica atwin
or paul would face a non-confidence vote
on july 20th
that could put her job in peril well
paul spent the day
thinking about that threat and then
rejected it
the plan of this small group of
counselors who are on their way out
did not succeed then noting that she is
the first black woman the first jewish
woman
to be elected to lead a federal party
she rejected the attempt by those five
counselors to
she put it make her conform to special
rules
i do not need a bespoke set of rules
established for me
and i haven't asked for any special
accommodation
but i am seeking the same freedom
to uh to lead and fulfill my role
as leader of the green party on behalf
of our members
collaboration and congeal and
collegiality
does not mean bowing down
it doesn't mean being brought to heal
strong words david so she's defiant in
the face of this attempted mutiny by
some in the party
what happens next well this governing
council is going to meet again on july
the 20th and if they want to make good
on this threat
to hold a no-confidence vote and kick
paul out well
a three-quarters majority will be
required at that meeting and i
think paul has looked at the numbers and
she is convinced that she has enough
support on the council
to defeat that vote and she probably
wants to end this spat pretty quickly
because you know as you know
her big task is readying the greens for
a potential general election late this
summer
maybe in the fall and if she cannot
strengthen the greens well
that would be a net benefit for other
parties in eastern canada
justin trudeau's liberals worry about
losing votes to
a green surge in the west and especially
in bc
it's jugmeet singh's ndp that is
vulnerable to the green so
a lot at stake here for all parties as
paul
tries to get control of her own party
donna david aiken in ottawa thank you
there are new signs tonight the cost of
living in canada is accelerating
the inflation rate is an indicator of
that and it rose 3.6 percent last month
to its highest level in a decade it
means canadians are paying more for
just about everything our senior
business correspondent ann gaviola
explains why and
what it could mean for interest rates in
the months ahead
the price of many consumer goods
collapsed at the onset of the pandemic
as people stayed home
less driving meant dramatically lower
prices at the pumps
bricks and mortar stores shuttered
pushing the price of clothes down
but as more parts of the economy reopen
prices
are climbing overall inflation jumped
3.6 percent in may nearly half of that
was because of
energy prices they rose more than 26
percent
food prices climbed one and a half
percent in the price of a passenger
vehicle new or used rose 5
the hot housing market is reflected in
the latest inflation numbers
an item called homeowner's replacement
is up 11
one area of the index that's shown quite
a significant
increase has been this component which
really is tracking what it would cost to
replace your home should you have to
do so this tracks the price of new homes
so elevated lumber prices are reflected
there too
we can't grow a tree within a year so
that
might stay for a while the global
microchip processor shortage which has
driven car prices skyward could have
staying power
but some of the inflationary pressures
are temporary as travel will
reopen we're anticipating that this will
create some
inflation but that will go away slowly
as
this year finishes and 2022 unfold
economists say as we transition from
buying up goods furniture sporting
equipment and groceries
to services going out and eating in
restaurants
that will relieve some of the price
pressures and this shift could mean
more money in the pockets of workers who
are in demand we are
seeing a significant increase in
inflationary forces
something that we haven't seen in a
while and the big question
is to what extent all those forces will
last long enough
for the bank of canada to start losing
sleep over it and start raising interest
rates
ann gaviola global news
efforts are ramping up to contain the
rapid spread of kovid 19 in a remote
indigenous community in ontario
there's a surge of cases in kosciuan and
children account for more than half of
the 232 active cases now
some help has arrived 15 nurses three
paramedics and another 16 red cross
members are on the ground
that's according to indigenous services
minister mark miller
he says the virus has spread like
wildfire
this will be a difficult week for
kasheshwan um but there is a real surge
of capacity and
and resources getting in this outbreak
is
perhaps a sad reminder that covet is
still here
and is very dangerous particularly if
you have not been vaccinated
chief leo friday says overcrowding and
the lack of places for sick people to
isolate is fueling the spread of the
virus
keshewan now accounts for a quarter of
all active cases reported
in indigenous communities across canada
the vancouver couple who chartered a
plane to fly to a yukon community to get
vaccinated early
have pleaded guilty rod and ekaterina
baker appeared via video link in a white
horse courtroom
they pleaded guilty to two charges under
yukon's civil emergency
measures act and they were fined about
twenty three hundred dollars
in january the couple flew to the remote
community of beaver creek
they posed as motel workers to get
vaccine doses
meant for locals and ignored mandatory
quarantine rules
the federal transport minister says
airlines and airports on both sides of
the canada-us border
have the wheels in motion now for a
phased reopening
of international travel though no
timelines have been given
certainly we need to give them uh time
to prepare for reopening
and we feel confident that our
partnership with them
and their dedicated and committed
workers and teams will be ready to uh
to work with us
details will be unveiled in the days
ahead
life will change for people who are
fully vaccinated as of tonight just over
14 percent of canadians have had
both doses 65 percent have had at least
one dose there is a section of the
population though who aren't eligible
for covet vaccines including children
under the age of twelve
as heather urex west reports it's not
clear when that could change
and it's leading to lots of questions
about summer travel
one-year-old willis steffensen was born
shortly before the pandemic began
and over in the uk her grandparents are
anxious for a visit
they're dying to see them like they
change so much when they're so young and
it's really sad it's sad that you know
the grandparents are missing out on all
the time when all this development and
you know all the funny things that they
do but while mom and dad will soon
receive their second covid19 vaccine
dose
willa and her three-year-old brother
remain unprotected
for the stefanssons it means putting any
plans for international travel
on hold to get an airplane with our kids
not vaccinated
definitely makes us a bit anxious still
after 14 months of restrictions many
families are eager to make travel plans
right now there's been a huge demand
ever since the announcement of last week
where the quarantine is going to be
lifted for
future travel except that announcement
was for canadians who are fully
vaccinated kids under 12 likely won't
have that option
until next year until then kids will be
protected by having
the adults around them vaccinated and
also by having less covet in the
community as a whole
international travel is a little more
complicated
kids may be less likely to become
seriously ill from covet but they could
still
import new variants it's important for
these canadians to remember that
although we're in a
good place right now with that third
wave coming right down
there are many places in the world where
copenhagen pandemic is still raging
concerns kellner says could be addressed
with country specific travel guidance
for families
which could include additional screening
and quarantine time for unimmunized kids
the federal government is expected to
update international travel and border
restrictions soon
families like the stefansson's hoping
those rules provide them with some
clarity
heather urex west global news calgary
shelling out cash to help solve a labor
shortage coming up how some provinces
are trying to entice nurses back to the
profession
plus parachuting protester the apologies
for this daring stunt
healthcare workers have faced so much
trauma throughout this pandemic
many are exhausted and some have left
the profession altogether
there was already a nursing shortage in
canada and now it's even worse
as jaime morocco explains some provinces
are offering big bucks to try to lure
them back
after 17 months of long grueling shifts
toronto emergency room nurse erim
chagalla says
she's burnt out it's been emotionally
challenging physically draining chigalla
says nurses are overworked and
severely understaffed and the kovit 19
pandemic has only made the situation
worse
they have decided to leave the
profession
or are planning to leave the profession
very soon
according to statistics canada in
january for the third month in a row
health care and social assistance had
more job vacancies than any other sector
now provinces are responding with cash
we've needed to create
a number of new positions to manage the
volumes
in ottawa the queensway carlton hospital
tweeted an offer of 10 thousand dollars
to any nurse willing to relocate to the
region
pei has been offering a one-time five
thousand dollar bonus for frontline
workers who stay for two years
while windsor regional hospital is
targeting nurses across the border
with up to a 75 thousand dollar signing
bonus
the government incentives are really um
to help us
not to you know you know steal from
peter to pay paul
so much as to bring nurses back to our
community
that is short-term band-aid for a
long-term
problem doris grinspun the ceo of the
registered nurses association of ontario
wants to see provincial governments
focus on base pay
tuition incentives and professional
development instead
investments on retention first and
recruitment second
jagala agrees i do think that we should
also try
incentives to retain our current staff
members
the pandemic hasn't been all bad for the
industry in fact
it's actually boosted enrollment in
nursing programs countrywide
in ontario 2 000 new educational spots
were added in may
but experts say there needs to be
thousands more
to fill the gap jamie morocco global
news toronto
ahead a powerful farewell from an mp who
says she was never welcome
in ottawa
we've made strides in canada lowering
the barriers to running for public
office and encouraging a diverse range
of people to get involved but
being an mp is not easy and not everyone
who wins an election thrives in ottawa
the ndp mp for nunavut is one of them
she has decided not
to run again twenty-seven-year-old
momolakka [ __ ] from baker lake
was elected in 2019 she is a proud inuk
woman
and the territories only mp in her
farewell speech to the house of commons
on tuesday
she said she was racially profiled by
security guards and
never felt safe or protected here is
part of her speech
the federal institution needs to change
its own policies and procedures to
reflect
reflect reality instead of creating
barriers for people like me
i shouldn't be afraid of going into work
no one should be afraid of going into
work
it is possible to create change
it can be started here in the house of
commons and reflected
in canada there is a refusal
and unwillingness for change not on
an inability to accomplish it
people don't like me don't belong here
in the federal institution
i'm a human being who wants to use this
institution to help people
but the reality is that this institution
and the country
has been created off the backs
trauma and displacement of indigenous
people
even if we're told we should run we
still face huge barriers
my life in canada and especially through
this experience
has taught me many things as a brown
woman do not move too quickly or
suddenly
do not raise your voice do not make a
scene
maintain eye contact and don't hide your
hands
every enok has survival mode we have to
i have heard so many pretty words like
reconciliation
diversity and inclusion i have been
called courageous
brave and strong by people outside of my
party
but let me be honest brutally honest
nice words with no action
hurt when they are uttered by those with
power
a red card for greenpeace next a protest
sends soccer fans
to hospital
soccer players at a euro 2020 match got
a surprise when an activist literally
dropped in
a parachute from greenpeace disrupted
the match between france and germany he
claims he intended to fly
over the stadium but lost control he
almost hit some
fans he ended up landing on the field
debri fell on the field in the main
grandstand just missing the french
manager
two people were injured and the
government says police could have shot
the activists down
greenpeace has apologized for the stunt
and one of soccer's biggest stars might
have cost coca-cola billions of dollars
because of his healthy
choices
[Music]
so much for branding cristiano ronaldo
urged people to drink water
at the european championship after
pushing aside those two coke bottles
right after his advice the beverage
titan stock plummeted wiping out 4
billion
in market value coca-cola is a sponsor
of euro 2020 and in a statement it said
everyone is entitled to their drink
preferences
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is this close-up shot of a
hummingbird coming in for a landing in
vale mount bc thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye